Trascrizione: Lucia Cadamuro
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Scusate un attimo,
ma sto pulendo
questo bellissimo tappeto,
rosso e circolare, dove mi trovo.
E sapete perché lo sto facendo?
Perché questa in realtà sarà la mia casa,
ovvero il luogo dove abiterò
per i prossimi dieci,
15 minuti della mia vita.
E a me piace vivere
in una casa che sia pulita.
Pensateci un attimo:
anche voi, in realtà,
che siete qui in questo momento,
state abitando questo bellissimo palazzo
dove noi tutti ci troviamo.
E lo abiteremo insieme,
finché ognuno di noi
non deciderà di andare via,
di tornare a casa
o di spostarsi da un'altra parte.
Lo so, forse ho esagerato un po':
ma l'ho fatto perché volevo
enfatizzare questo concetto.
Ovvero di come, in realtà,
sia l'azione di essere e di abitare
uno spazio, un luogo
a rendere quel luogo un'abitazione,
e non il contrario.
In tal senso, ovunque io sono io abito:
e per farlo non devo, necessariamente,
possedere quello spazio.
Questo è un concetto apparentemente
molto semplice da comprendere,
ma al tempo stesso è un concetto
estremamente rivoluzionario
perché sfida il sentire comune
e arriva, addirittura,
a mettere in discussione
l'etimologia stessa della parola abitare,
che deriva dal verbo latino "habere",
la quale ci dice che per abitare
dobbiamo avere o possedere con continuità
un determinato spazio.
Essere, o avere.
Noi tutti siamo cresciuti con l'idea
che felicità sia sinonimo di stabilità.
Il posto fisso di lavoro,
la casa di proprietà,
sicurezze economiche ed affettive
sono gli obiettivi imposti
dalla nostra cultura.
Più cose - e purtroppo,
a volte anche persone -
noi possediamo, o pensiamo di possedere
e più ci sentiamo sicuri,
soddisfatti, realizzati.
Nel corso del tempo, ci siamo convinti
che se vogliamo concludere qualcosa
di buono nella nostra vita,
dobbiamo necessariamente
mettere radici, come degli alberi.
Dobbiamo cioè scegliere un luogo
dove vivere stabilmente,
e intorno a questo costruire
tutte le nostre certezze.
In questa logica, la nostra casa
diventa il punto di riferimento,
lo specchio riflesso della nostra
identità culturale e sociale,
il punto fermo,
il fulcro intorno a cui ruota
ogni altro aspetto della nostra esistenza.
Questo è il motivo per cui noi italiani
dedichiamo gran parte
della nostra esistenza lavorativa
nell'accumulare le risorse economiche
che ci servono per acquistare
e per mantenere una casa.
Di media,
il 70% di ciò che guadagniamo
in tutta la nostra vita
lo spendiamo per acquistare una casa,
per mantenerla, per arredarla,
per ristrutturarla,
per pagare gli interessi sul mutuo
e le relative tasse di proprietà.
Questo è un modello di business
eccezionale, se ci pensiamo:
soprattutto per le banche,
per i costruttori e anche per lo Stato.
Forse, però, pochi di voi sanno
che in Italia si contano
oltre sette milioni di appartamenti vuoti.
Gli appartamenti residenziali in Italia
sono circa 31 milioni,
e l'offerta è dieci volte
superiore alla domanda:
Eppure, si continua a costruire.
C'è un altro dato che io trovo
particolarmente interessante,
che ci dice che il 40% degli italiani
impiega più di un'ora
del proprio tempo, ogni giorno,
per compiere il percorso che va da casa
al proprio posto di lavoro,
e uno su cinque spende più
del 10% della propria retribuzione
per relativi costi di trasporto.
Io credo che sia arrivato
un attimo il momento
di fermarsi a riflettere
e di porci una domanda:
ma siamo davvero sicuri
che in un momento storico di cambiamento
e di trasformazione epocale,
come quello che noi stiamo vivendo,
questo modello di sviluppo
basato sulla stanzialità,
sulla ricerca del posto fisso di lavoro,
sull'acquisto di una casa di proprietà,
sia quello più giusto da seguire
ma soprattutto da trasmettere
alle nuove generazioni?
Io mi sono posto
diverse volte questa domanda,
ma purtroppo non ho una risposta.
Voglio però raccontarvi
una brevissima storia.
Il bambino che vedete in questa foto
in realtà sono io, quando avevo
più o meno cinque o sei anni.
Questa è una foto che risale
ai primi anni 70,
quando ancora internet,
le console dei videogiochi,
i social network e gli smartphone
non esistevano.
Noi bambini per giocare
ci incontravamo al prato,
oppure scendevamo nel cortile sotto casa.
All'epoca, in quegli anni,
la produzione industriale,
e l'economia industriale,
erano in forte ascesa,
la richiesta di manodopera
era molto elevata
e il lavoro era relativamente
semplice da trovare,
e altrettanto semplice era mantenerlo.
Normalmente, quando si entrava
in azienda, oppure in fabbrica,
vi si rimaneva fino al pensionamento.
In quegli anni, per acquistare
una casa di proprietà, possederla,
dove poter vivere
tutto il resto della propria vita
con la propria famiglia,
magari in una grande città del nord
oppure in un grande centro urbano,
rappresentava il vero sogno,
il miracolo italiano.
Per la maggior parte
delle persone, infatti,
questo non era semplicemente un obiettivo,
ma piuttosto un traguardo
definitivo da raggiungere.
Ora vi invito nuovamente
a guardare questa foto.
Io credo che avete tutti immaginato:
mamma mia quanto sei cambiato?
Sì, sono completamente cambiato.
All'epoca ero un bel bimbo:
ora sono molto più brutto.
Ho perso i capelli,
mi è cresciuta anche la pancia.
Ma la verità è che non sono
solo io, ad essere cambiato.
È il mondo in cui noi viviamo,
ad essere completamente diverso
rispetto a prima.
Io credo, quindi,
che servano necessariamente
nuovi punti di riferimento,
nuovi modelli da seguire.
Perché quelli passati
semplicemente non esistono più,
come non esiste più
quel bambino in questa foto.
Purtroppo, che ci piaccia o meno,
sono sparite quel genere
di sicurezze e di certezze
di cui hanno potuto godere
le generazioni precedenti.
E difficilmente potranno tornare.
Noi di questo dobbiamo
farcene una ragione.
C'è però qualcosa di nuovo,
qualcosa di rivoluzionario,
che sta avvenendo.
Oggi infatti,
grazie alle tecnologie digitali -
posso avere un po' d'acqua, per favore?
per la prima volta
abbiamo una grandissima opportunità.
Ovvero quella di poter slegare
la posizione fisica
dall'opportunità economica.
Le classiche strutture aziendali,
le postazioni di lavoro in ufficio,
stanno infatti lasciando sempre più spazio
a modelli organizzativi
alternativi, flessibili.
Il lavoro non si svolge più
in uno spazio statico,
e ad orari prestabiliti:
ma ovunque, in qualsiasi momento
e su qualsiasi device.
Oggi, potenzialmente -
Oggi, potenzialmente,
ogni luogo diventa un luogo di lavoro:
la nostra casa, lo spazio di coworking,
la biblioteca, la libreria,
anche il bar sotto casa, il parco.
D'ora in avanti,
noi non saremo più costretti
a doverci spostare per andare a lavorare.
Ma potremmo spostarci portandoci
dietro il nostro lavoro,
ovunque noi decideremo di andare.
Non so quanti di voi lo sanno:
ma già adesso, in questo momento,
oltre il 16% delle aziende
in tutto il mondo
concede ai propri dipendenti
la possibilità di lavorare
ovunque, da remoto.
E questa rivoluzione è appena iniziata.
Io, da oltre 12 anni,
mi occupo di sperimentare,
di studiare, di divulgare
la cultura del lavoro da remoto,
il nomadismo digitale in Italia.
In questi anni ho avuto la fortuna,
il piacere di poter vivere e lavorare
in tanti luoghi diversi.
Come potete vedere da queste foto,
io adoro vivere e lavorare
a contatto con la natura.
La cosa che mi fa star meglio
è poter lavorare guardando il mare.
Perché passo diverse ore
davanti allo schermo
di un computer portatile,
e alzare lo sguardo, e vedere
questo orizzonte immenso e azzurro,
mi riempie di serenità.
In questi anni ho scoperto, anche,
che lavorare muovendosi
attraverso luoghi diversi
è un fattore abilitante,
perché ti permette di aumentare
la tua creatività,
di sviluppare nuove idee.
Ti permette di andare incontro
a nuove opportunità
personali e professionali,
ovunque esse si trovino.
Ma soprattutto,
ti permette di sperimentare
nuovi stili di vita,
e nuovi stili di lavoro,
che ti permettono di sentirti
più libero e più felice.
Il vantaggio più grande,
a mio modo di vedere,
del lavoro da remoto
è che ti permette di essere sempre
dove vuoi, quando vuoi.
Ed essere nel posto giusto
al momento giusto
significa saper ascoltare
di che cosa abbiamo bisogno
in quel momento per star bene.
La grande città; il piccolo paese;
il mare; la montagna;
la campagna; il borgo.
Ognuno di questi luoghi
può essere il posto giusto,
anzi il migliore in cui stare,
in base al ciclo di vita
che noi stiamo vivendo
e in base a quelle che, in quel momento,
sono le nostre esigenze
e i nostri bisogni.
Ora, vorrei farvi una domanda.
Provate un attimo a chiudere gli occhi:
concentratevi, se volete.
Immaginate che anche voi
abbiate la possibilità
di portarvi il vostro lavoro,
e la vostra carriera, ovunque.
Dove vi piacerebbe andare?
Come vi piacerebbe vivere?
Chi oggi pensa che il lavoro da remoto
sia semplicemente
un modo diverso di lavorare,
si sbaglia profondamente.
Il lavoro da remoto sta determinando
la più grande rivoluzione
della stanzialità umana.
Ma affinché questo processo
possa crescere, e possa evolversi,
è necessario sviluppare un nuovo paradigma
che ci permetta di sentirci a casa
in luoghi diversi.
Perché per star bene
è necessario "sentirsi a casa":
ovvero incontrare quello spazio,
fuori e dentro di noi,
dove noi possiamo sentirci al sicuro.
Possiamo essere liberi
di essere chi siamo.
Pensateci:
noi siamo la prima generazione al mondo
che può vivere il mondo lavorando
e contemporaneamente crescere,
conoscere persone simili,
connettersi con nuove realtà locali.
Che cosa dovrebbe impedirci di farlo?
Purtroppo il tempo
a mia disposizione è terminato,
per cui vorrei concludere
questo mio intervento con un messaggio,
con un messaggio che rivolgo
soprattutto alle nuove generazioni.
Grazie ai nostri nonni, ai vostri bisnonni
che hanno combattuto,
e che sono morti per questo,
voi oggi siete una generazione
di donne e di uomini liberi.
Non lasciatevi influenzare da nessuno,
e difendete questa conquista
come il bene più prezioso
che avete a vostra disposizione.
Se volete crescere, se volete evolvere
come professionisti e come persone civili,
sentitevi sempre liberi di restare,
liberi di andare e liberi di tornare.
Superate tutti gli stereotipi
e tutti i luoghi comuni.
E se volete essere felici,
non smettete mai di cercare
la vostra casa nel mondo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)